JEANNE MOOS: What happens
when you put a bunch
of introverted dogs together.
Take a look.
It's worse than the
office Christmas
party before the liquor flows.
Standing apart, all of
them avoiding eye contact.
One of the owners described
it as a pasture of cows
at a dog park in Sweden.
This Swedish couple shot
the video that went viral.
SOFIA ROSTEN: We found a group
that was for introverted dogs
and we thought it was perfect
for Qila because she--
JEANNE MOOS: Qila,
a rescued street dog
is selective about other
canines and has had only one
best friend, this wiener dog.
Instead of using the
word, introverted--
TIMMY BONTEGARD:
--gather more calm dogs.
JEANNE MOOS: --Sophia
at Timmy prefer calm.
The meet up lasted an hour.
The video shows only
the waning moments
when everyone seemed to have
had enough of each other.
Dogs thinking, this
could have been an email.
[laughing] The couple found
the group of calm dogs--
SOFIA ROSTEN: It's on Facebook
for different kind of dogs.
JEANNE MOOS:
[inaudible] does not
seem introverted with you two.
At the meetup, amid pooches
planted like statues,
two of the introverts passed
like ships in the night.
And though Qila may be the life
of the party with her owners,
she preferred catching
bugs in her mouth
to catching the eye of
any other introverts.
Jeanne Moos, CNN New York.